Narrator: The show that
revolutionized business is back.
In eight years,
with over $87 million invested
in the Tank thus far,
Shark Tank businesses
have generated
hundreds of
millions in sales...
Even you couldn't have predicted
this kind of breakout success.
O'Leary: No,
but it's taught all of us
what a platform
"Shark Tank" is.
...employed thousands...
LePage:
You're creating great jobs
for the people
in the state of Maine.
So keep them coming.
... and changed how America
does business.
President Obama: We have a lot
of brainpower here.
We even got a few Sharks.
"Shark Tank"'s become
an American phenomenon,
and the support of the President
just goes to show you
that the American dream
is alive and well.
Narrator:
From their humble beginnings,
the Sharks are all self‐made
and understand what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing.
And now they're here to help
other entrepreneurs
realize their dreams.
You guys are the American dream
come true.
You are why I do this show.
Narrator: Together they've
created monster successes...
Krause: Lori helped me get
into every Bed Bath & Beyond,
and now we've topped $85 million
in sales.
Narrator: ... and impacted
the world for the better.
Melissa: We were able to take
100 kids off the streets.
We chased our dreams, and now
we're seeing them come true.
The power of "Shark Tank"
is back.
Woman:
This has been a long road
and a lot of hard work,
and it's all coming true.
Some businesses are born in
hell, and this is one of them.
Ohh.
[ Crying ] It's just hard to go
through all of this.
This is
just the beginning.
Narrator:
And it all begins now.
It's not for the meek.
It's not for the weak.
‐You did it.
‐Whoo!
We got a deal!
I'm Kara Haught.
And I'm Shelly Hyde.
And we're sisters
and best friends
from St. Cloud, Florida.
We have always
been partners in crime.
From cutting
each other's bangs
to teaching each other
how to swim,
we knew
we made a good team.
Now that we have four kids each,
nothing much has changed.
We're continuing
on all of our adventures.
We just have four
little wild ones with us.
‐Whoo!
Our products empower
women and mothers like us
to beautifully
and confidently
enjoy life's adventures
to the fullest.
Here comes...
Being a mom
and a business owner
have a lot of the same
skill sets.
It's hard,
and it's exhausting.
At the end of the day,
you got to get kids in bed
and orders filled,
but it's worth it.
We have invested our own money
and tons of time into this,
but it's just the two of us
handling everything right now.
We need
another set of hands.
Without an investment
from the Sharks,
our business
might not succeed.
It's really pretty.
Behind it.
This moment
is a real pinnacle for us.
Crazy dance,
and then pull it together.
Okay, okay.
One, two, three.
Okay.
[ All vocalizing ]
Man:
Three, two, wall door!
♪♪
Corcoran: Wow.
Hi. I'm Shelly Hyde.
And I'm her little sister,
Kara Haught.
We're from
St. Cloud, Florida,
and we're seeking $100,000
for 20% of our company,
Raising Wild.
Sharks, we practically grew up
wearing swimsuits.
We were raised
in Florida,
so we did anything from
lobster diving to rope swinging.
[ Chuckles ]
You name it,
and we did it
in our bathing suits.
Shelly and I now
have four kids each,
and we haven't
slowed down.
But the suits of today
can't keep up with us.
'Cause guess what?
We're not kids anymore.
So our need in a swimsuit
has completely changed.
So, we've designed
our bathing suits
for fit, fashion,
and function.
Raising Wild
is the perfect solution
to the swimsuit struggle
for women like us.
Our cuts and colors
hit at the right places
to complement a beautiful
variety of body types.
But what really
sets Raising Wild apart
is our functionality,
'cause we've added
enough length in the body
and coverage in the booty
to allow free movement.
We even have
nursing‐friendly suits.
Shelly and I were raised
in a family
of 12 brothers and sisters.
Wow.
‐12.
Right, ladies?
These are our three
beautiful mom models,
who also happen
to be our test market
and our three older sisters.
Oh, wow.
Hyde:
So, we are pretty sure
that you can do just about
anything in Raising Wild,
including pitch
to an entire roomful...
Of hungry Sharks.
... of hungry Sharks.
[ Laughter ]
So, now, Sharks,
while the sissies pass out
your samples,
we're gonna slip
into something...
A little more professional.
... a little more professional.
Shelly, can we see Barbara
in one of these suits?
[ Laughs ]
‐We've got one for you.
‐I only wear bikinis.
That's it.
Thank you very much.
Kevin should
slip into one.
Greiner: Wow.
Corcoran: So, tell us
about the background
of how you got started
in the business.
So,
being raised in Florida,
we were always on
a swimsuit hunt ‐‐ always.
And so,
when we became mothers,
we were still looking
for bathing suits.
But the reason for swimsuits
changed for us.
But it seems shocking to me
in a state like Florida
that you couldn't find
phenomenal bathing suits.
Well, you can,
but gone are the days
of us just laying still
and looking pretty.
We still wanted
to have the edgy look
and the sophisticated look,
but still be able
to scoop down up my baby
and not have things
spill out.
Without your butt hanging out
the back, right?
‐Yes.
‐Yes!
Shelly,
how much are your suits?
So, our suits range
between $138 and $156.
Wow.
How does that compare
to the average?
It's ‐‐ It's roughly
around $60.
Oh, so you're ‐‐ you're
definitely higher‐end.
So you're higher‐end.
‐Yeah, we are.
‐Yeah, definitely.
What's
your average cost?
So, our average cost per suit
is roughly $38,
including materials.
Wow. That's a great margin.
Wow.
That's a great margin.
It's about 250% margin.
So, what is your total sales?
We can't wait to hear.
Our total sales
are $130,000.
That's not horrible.
Okay. That's not bad.
‐All sold online?
‐How did you sell it?
We have sold
direct to consumer,
and the only marketing
that we've done this far
is social media.
What's your vision?
How big do you think
you can get?
We actually feel
like this could go huge.
"Huge" isn't a number.
You have
about 800 customers.
Yeah.
So, how do you get
from 800 customers
to 8,000 customers?
We feel like if we can put
some money behind marketing,
that there are
potentially ‐‐
But that's not enough.
Yeah.
How you spend money
on marketing
is far more important
than how much you spend.
Completely agree, yeah.
And so, people get confused.
So, strategically,
you really have to dig in
and know how you're going
to test it
in order to get results.
Yeah.
Oh, for sure.
Tell me a little bit about
your ‐‐ your background
before you were moms.
Do you have
a career in retail?
Okay, so, we're moms.
[ Chuckles ]
That means that we're
pretty much good at
everything that we do.
We are masters at it all.
You haven't ‐‐ You haven't
worked formally
in this industry,
right?
Yeah, no, but ‐‐
No, we haven't.
I'm gonna make
a prediction.
There's no chance in hell
you're getting $100,000
from any
of these Sharks here...
...because there's nothing
to invest in here.
At the end of the day,
"Shark Tank"
is about making money,
about investing in companies
that can provide returns.
I don't think this
is an investable company.
I'm out.
Okay, so, right now
we're doing women's suits.
We're expanding
to kids' suits.
And as we plan out
our new products,
we have this captive audience
of purchasing mothers.
You got to be
really careful, right?
When you walked in,
you said you were good
at one thing ‐‐ two things ‐‐
designing suits
and using social media
to sell them.
Yeah.
When we talk about growth,
we're gonna add new lines,
we're gonna expand
our marketing,
we're gonna get into retail.
Mm‐hmm.
Like, that takes you away
from the organic growth
that you've been good at.
You've got
to be really careful,
because you go too wide
too fast, you drown.
‐Yeah. Well ‐‐
‐Right.
You can drown
in opportunity.
Yeah.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Greiner: Ladies...
Yes.
...I feel you have
a really long way to go,
a lot of work to do.
Okay.
So I don't see this
as an investment for me.
Okay.
I'm out.
So, ladies, you know,
the journey of a thousand miles
starts with a single footstep.
You've done one footstep.
Catering for a swimsuit strictly
because you're mom‐oriented ‐‐
I just don't think
it's sustainable enough.
I think this is
a very, very tough business
with a lot of big players.
I wish you all the best,
but it's way too soon for me.
I'm out.
Okay, well, thank you.
Okay.
What I wanted to say was that
we aren't gonna stop.
And we would love to have
a strategic partner and...
We'll get there.
... some infusion of cash
to be able
to get there faster.
Yep.
You know, every entrepreneur
that comes into the Tank
is loaded with passion.
The earlier in the game,
the more passion they have,
but it's never really enough.
Yeah.
I totally believe
you're committed.
Is there anything you could
point to in your past
that would help me feel
as though you have
accomplished something
in the business world ‐‐
even a small thing ‐‐
or stuck with
some personal journey
that you've ‐‐ that you've
seen through to the finish line?
I‐I have a son
that was just a couple years ago
diagnosed with ADHD.
This was not the plan
to tell you about this, but...
[ Voice breaking ] Okay.
He's amazing,
but he was given a reading
and a writing disability,
and they told us
it would be years
before he would be
at grade level
and that we should
hold him back.
But we spent all of
our extra time after
school helping him,
and we take him to early‐morning
classes before school every day.
We dedicated our time.
And this year,
at the end of the school year,
he was reading
above his grade level.
He was the
second‐highest‐scoring kid
in his math class.
So, I feel like, yeah, I don't
have a business background
to say, "Look,
here it is, here I am,"
but I can work harder than
any person that is doing that,
and I've proven that.
You couldn't have hit
on a better story.
It has nothing to do
with business.
But when I go home at night,
after I've finished my workday,
I spend at least
an hour and a half
with my daughter, Kate,
who's 10, who is ADHD.
My son's 10.
She can't read.
She has
a processing disorder.
Mm‐hmm.
But what I have
is a little girl
with the confidence to the moon
because she has a mother
that is totally behind her.
So, I think a mom
that could see that through,
play that hand out,
and stay with it
is probably one
of the most underestimated
accomplishments in life.
‐Thank you.
‐It is true.
But let me tell you ‐‐ there's
a lot wrong with the business.
You have a mom niche that is
way too narrow, way too narrow,
because it's just a mom play.
And I've just not seen
any of them
that really work out.
Those are large obstacles
to overcome.
I am gonna make an offer...
but I feel like I have to make
a greedy offer.
♪♪
Narrator: Four Sharks are out,
but Barbara is interested
in Shelly and Kara's
swimsuit company,
Raising Wild.
I am gonna make an offer...
but I feel like I have to make
a greedy offer.
I feel bad things
are going to happen.
I'd like to take 51%
of the business.
Ooh.
Ohh.
‐Wow. So much love.
‐[ Whistles ]
So, you understand
that Barbara's taking control
of that business?
It's just, I think you need an
experienced hand to guide you.
Yeah.
My offer is contingent
on you selling these suits
for $99.
You think about that.
Okay.
$99 ‐‐ I think they'll
fly off the shelf.
And I think, most important,
I want you to name each model
suit after one of your sisters
and have that sister model it,
because I just think
it's gonna be really cool
that you have a huge family,
you take advantage of it.
We feel like we've worked
really hard for this company,
and it's really ‐‐
it's ‐‐ it's hard to give up
part of our baby like that.
We want to counter
with 35% for $100,000.
I'll tell you what ‐‐
I'll go to 50/50...
[ Exhales sharply ]
... but not 35%.
So, you're not gonna go
any lower?
No, I won't ‐‐ No.
But I'll be there
with credit lines
if you need more cash.
Oh, this is just so hard.
I just...
But you have
to make a decision.
Tough deals are that ‐‐
they're tough.
We just can't give up
50% of our baby.
Cuban: Let ‐‐ Let me help, guys.
That's like sending
two of my kids ‐‐
Guys, let me help.
15% is the difference, right?
If you think
you can grow the business
more than an extra 15%
with Barbara's help,
that's
the decision‐making factor.
So don't try
to just hold on to equity,
because the percentages
aren't what's important.
It's the value.
♪♪
Let's do it.
[ Laughs ]
I really feel like
that's the right thing.
Greiner: Good deal, Barb.
I want this suit
in every color.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
Great job, really great.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Thank you so...
Greiner: Good luck, you guys.
Gotcha.
‐Congratulations.
‐Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Haught: Well, that took us
completely by surprise.
We were not expecting
a 50% deal from Barbara.
No.
To consider it,
we will never get to where
we can go with Barbara
on our own,
so we're more than happy
to give up the 50%.
John: I'm in Silicon Valley
for the seventh annual
Global Entrepreneurship Summit
at Stanford University.
Last year, President Obama
named me as a PAGE ‐‐
Presidential Ambassador
for Global Entrepreneurship.
The PAGE program
has three pillars ‐‐
increasing access to capital,
education, and mentorship.
I had no idea about
the power of "Shark Tank"
all around the globe.
People from all around
the world ‐‐ 170 countries ‐‐
have been coming up to me
and telling me
how "Shark Tank" has helped
change their lives.
One of the best ways to help
the Cuban people succeed
and improve their lives
would be for the U. S. Congress
to lift the embargo.
John: And a few months ago,
I joined President Obama
on his historic mission
to open the doors to Cuba.
We've got a Shark here
named Daymond John.
John:
We empowered the Cuban people
through technology and business.
For the first time,
their right to have a business
was recognized
by their government.
Welcome to
the United States of America.
[ Cheers and applause ]
John: And now I'm here
at this year's summit
to help showcase the best
in entrepreneurship in America.
I'm here with President Obama,
Secretary of Commerce
Penny Pritzker,
and my fellow PAGE ambassadors.
I never expected that I would be
a little brown boy from Queens,
and now I'm sitting next to the
President of the United States.
My message to all entrepreneurs
is, believe in yourself.
You can do it.
Thank you very much.
I came from nothing
and built my own success,
and now I'm working directly
with the President
of the United States.
You have been outstanding.
When I come to these events,
I still pinch myself.
I'm talking to the President,
I'm meeting people that have
overcome huge obstacles,
and I'm so proud
to be part of it.
Narrator: Next up is a new brand
from a cookie legend.
[ Corcoran laughs ]
[ Herjavec chuckles ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Aloha, Sharks.
My name is Wally Amos.
I'm known as the Cookie Man.
‐Yes, you are.
‐Wow.
Oh, wow.
My new company
is The Cookie Kahuna,
and I am
from Honolulu, Hawaii,
asking for $50,000.
That's chump change
for you guys...
[ Laughs ]
...in exchange for 20%.
I've been selling cookies
for 40 years.
And for a long time,
I actually thought
I was selling cookies.
But it occurred to me that
I wasn't selling cookies.
I was selling happiness.
You ‐‐ You ‐‐ You guys are ‐‐
You're not smiling.
I mean, I ‐‐ And this guy ‐‐
I'm smiling.
I'm smiling, Wally.
Come on. Bring it.
This guy in the middle,
though ‐‐ Mr. Wonderful ‐‐
he looks anything
but wonderful!
[ Laughter ]
Ohh!
I got something
that'll make you smile.
Don't go away.
Is he the Amos of Famous ‐‐
‐Yeah. Yeah.
‐Yeah.
‐Wow.
‐He's the famous Amos.
[ Kazoo playing ]
[ Laughs ]
♪ Cookies for the Sharks ♪
[ Laughter ]
‐This is gonna end badly.
‐Oh, very badly.
Are you guys ‐‐ Is anybody here
allergic to cookies?
You know, you guys look the same
as you do on television.
Shocking, isn't it?
I can't believe I'm this close
to the Sharks.
Let me give Lori hers.
Does it matter?
Amos: No,
it doesn't matter to me.
All right.
I'm gonna shortcut it
for you, buddy.
Thank you.
So, let me get Barbara's
and mine.
Here. Give me mine.
‐You got yours?
You're lactose ‐‐
You're a legend.
Am I a legend?
‐Thank you.
‐You are a legend.
Does that mean y'all gonna
give me some money?
No, but you are a legend.
Oh, my gosh!
[ Laughter ]
You're as tough
as everybody said you were.
I like them.
Yeah. They're good.
Corcoran: You have
a light, crunchy cookie.
It's good.
‐Yeah.
I am the Wally Amos
who started Famous Amos
40 years ago.
You are a legend, sir.
Oh, God.
‐Yes.
‐Yes, sir.
‐Very impressed.
‐Yes.
Well, so are all of you guys.
Thank you very much.
That's ‐‐ That's
very gracious of you.
I appreciate that.
I have a new cookie business,
which is called
The Cookie Kahuna.
I am no longer affiliated
with the original company
that I started 40 years ago.
What happened
to that company?
I came to cookies
from show business.
Years ago, I was an agent
at William Morris.
I was the first African‐American
agent at William Morris.
Wow.
I booked Simon & Garfunkel,
the Supremes, Marvin Gaye.
I did that for a long time.
Wow.
I started making cookies, 1970,
just to share with friends
and just to have cookies
whenever I wanted to.
But your cookies
were everywhere,
all over the world.
Oh, they were.
They were.
What went wrong was,
I'm a damn good promoter,
but I'm ‐‐ I'm not
a business guy.
And my focus was not on how much
money I was gonna make.
I just wanted to have
a good time.
So, what happened
with the business?
They're ‐‐ They're
still avail‐‐
The company went
through five different owners
over a period of time.
‐Wow.
‐Really?
By the time, I got down,
I'd been diluted,
and I had no equity left.
I had nothing left.
They use, I believe,
your picture on the box?
My picture is still
on the packaging.
And they have the name
"Famous Amos"?
Yes, they do.
So, did they ‐‐ did they
license that from you?
No. They own Famous Amos...
They own it.
... right out.
Tell us about
the new business.
I started this maybe a little
over a year and a half ago.
We're online.
I've got my own website.
And I sell cookies at Costco
only in Hawaii.
What do you sell it for,
Wally?
How much does it cost?
Hold on a sec.
I'm not a business guy,
but I got my numbers here.
[ Laughter ]
We liked our numbers.
Yeah, we do.
Oh, yeah,
you love your numbers.
You love your numbers
like I love my cookies.
Costco buys them for $7.89
for a one‐pound bag.
And how much does it
cost you to make them?
And it costs $5.25 ‐‐
$4.20 for ingredients.
What were your sales
for the last year?
$36,215.97
for this year so far.
Can I see the numbers, Wally?
Do you mind?
No, not at all.
Thank you, sir.
Don't ask me any questions,
though.
You're holding the numbers,
okay?
I'll answer them for you.
That wouldn't be fair.
So, Wally,
the margin you're making,
once you take in packaging,
shipping, and handling...
Mm‐hmm.
... is less than 20%.
That's bad...
Mm‐hmm.
... in the food business.
It's ‐‐ That's not
enough margin...
Mm‐hmm.
... to sustain a business.
You've got to get
your costs down.
Mm‐hmm.
What the numbers tell me
is your packaging
and shipping costs
are well over 40%
of the whole cost, so ‐‐
Including
the baked goods.
‐No. No.
‐What?
Just the packaging.
Wally, that's worse
than I thought.
Wally, after what
you've been through...
Mm‐hmm.
... starting the business,
losing the business...
Mm‐hmm.
... why would you start
all over again?
Because I love cookies,
and I think that I can build
the business out of this cookie
and replicate what I did
with Famous Amos years ago.
I'm convinced I can.
One thing you bring
that very few people
that have ever come
on the Tank have had
is such a huge brand associated
with the food category.
Mm‐hmm.
But we don't have
the full access
of your image
and your name,
and so it has
all the challenges
associated
with launching a new brand.
It's not investable ‐‐
not for me, anyways.
Okay. I accept that.
I'm sorry, Wally.
I'm out.
That's cool.
No problem.
Thank you. Thank you.
Greiner: I'm a product person.
I've been in the product arena
for 18 years.
Mm‐hmm.
And I've worked
with a lot of entrepreneurs.
And one of the things
that's the hardest conversation
I ever have to have with them
is about,
if they find
that something isn't working,
to go to something else.
And I'm sure,
because you have that spirit ‐‐
you're a promoter, you have
so much inside of you ‐‐
that there are other things
that you could be doing
with as much passion instead ‐‐
I understand.
I understand what you're saying.
Because of that struggle,
I have to be out.
I understand that.
I accept all of that, sure.
Everybody knows your cookie.
You're a solid entrepreneur.
It's good
to love the product.
It's really important
to love the business.
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐Your cost is too high.
You have
limited distribution.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Best of luck.
‐That's cool.
‐Yeah.
I accept that.
Thank you, man.
Yeah. Thank you.
Corcoran: I have
a similar story to you.
If not for a lucky break,
I would have had the exact, same
thing happen in my business.
I was in business
about 10 years,
and I had a terrible turn
in the market.
And, lucky for me, just
when I thought I might
go out of business,
Merrill Lynch came in...
Uh‐huh.
... and they offered me
$50,000.
They not only wanted me
to sign away Corcoran Group,
which was my brand...
Mm‐hmm.
... but they wanted me to sign
away "Barbara Corcoran."
Mm‐hmm.
For me,
where I was seated then...
Right.
...$50,000
was the equivalent
of having God himself
come down and kiss me.
[ Laughs ]
I can relate.
And at the 11th hour,
they changed their mind
and didn't buy it.
Mm‐hmm.
And that same business,
I sold for $66 million
15 years later.
How lucky for me
that they changed their mind.
Yeah.
You know, the universe
is filled with surprises.
It's true.
But where's what
went awry here.
When you sold your business,
you not only sold the name,
but you sold your personality
along with it.
Without that, the business
has very little value.
Barbara,
what are you gonna do?
Too late.
She's not ‐‐
She's gonna pass.
Yeah, looks like it.
Yeah, I'm gonna pass,
but with great respect.
Right, right.
Cuban:
Wally, you're a legend.
I've learned from your story,
the good and the bad,
and it taught me a lot.
My problem is, I'm already
in the cookie business.
Mm‐hmm.
So it would be
a conflict for me.
Oh, no question.
So I'm out.
But thank you.
Stay tuned.
You'll watch me selling cookies.
I have no doubt,
no doubt.
[ Laughter ]
Come on, Wally.
You got to go.
[ Laughter ]
Aloha.
Alo‐o‐oha!
♪ Da‐da, da‐da‐da ♪
All: Alo‐o‐oha!
Aloha, guys!
‐Good luck, Wally.
‐See you Wally. Good luck.
[ Kazoo playing ]
Amos: I just know that this was
just another step in my journey.
So, Cookie Kahuna is gonna be
more famous than Famous Amos.
So, you guys know
the whole story of Wally?
It's an amazing lesson.
So, business was great.
He was the first,
like, high‐end cookie
that got distributed
in grocery stores.
And then that brought in
some competition,
and so business
started to decline,
and so he went out
and got an investor.
But he still,
you know ‐‐
He said, "Okay,
just give me the money.
That'll fix it all."
It didn't, and every time
he lost equity
and burned
through the cash,
he raised more money.
So he kept on getting diluted
until it was nothing.
What I did love about him is,
he was 80 years old,
and he still had the the fire,
he still had the drive.
How many of us
up here at 80 ‐‐
He had a personality.
You look great for 80, Robert.
Come on.
[ Chuckles ]
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is first aid
for our beloved tech devices.
♪♪
Hi. I'm Adam Cookson.
Hi. I'm Craig Beinecke.
We're from
Denver, Colorado.
Our company is TekDry.
We're seeking $500,000
in exchange for 5%
of our company.
[ Exhales ]
Sharks...
this toilet stands
before you today
guilty
of a terrible crime ‐‐
[ Chuckles ]
Murder.
That's right.
This porcelain perpetrator
is the number‐one reason
people lose phones
to water damage.
[ Light laughter ]
It doesn't stop there.
Toilets, swimming pools,
washing machines.
Each year in the U. S.,
these kill 22 million phones
with water damage.
We've invented a machine
that can bring phones,
tablets, laptops, watches ‐‐
basically anything that fits
in the chamber ‐‐
back to life.
‐Wow.
‐It's not magic.
It's science!
[ Laughter ]
Have a look inside our machine
in real time,
transforming liquid
into gas,
restoring your phone
in just 30 minutes.
No need to disassemble
or take anything apart.
Sharks,
this is my personal phone.
It has no
special protection.
But I'm not worried.
‐No!
I'm not worried.
[ All scream ]
Aah!
You murderer!
[ Laughs ]
So, let's make a deal,
Sharks.
This is one opportunity
you don't want to flush away.
Corcoran: Oh, gosh.
[ Chuckles ]
I'm gonna take a moment
to rescue this phone
and then show you
our process.
This is a gut‐wrenching moment
for customers.
[ Chuckles ]
Bring it in for service
as quick as you can.
Your device starts rusting
as soon as it gets wet.
So, inside the chamber,
we have special metallic beads.
What these do
is surround any device inside
with a warm, gentle heat.
The device...
[ Beads rustle ]
... goes inside.
Then what the machine
will do
is remove all of the air
from the chamber.
And the combination of that
plus the gentle heat
turns all the liquid
into gas
and makes it leave the phone
instantly.
‐Oh, wow.
‐Interesting.
By the time that you get
into the machine,
maybe the phone's gone.
So, I feel
it's like a heart attack.
You got to get CPR fast.
Right.
You want to come
as quick as possible,
and certainly best results
are the same day it got wet,
but we've saved devices
several days later.
Really? So, technically,
someone could ship it to you.
Like, are you online,
or are you a store?
Yeah.
We're currently
in 82 big‐box retail stores,
as well as we have
a mail‐in service.
But what are your sales?
So, last year,
with just a few stores,
we did $29,000.
No, you didn't say a few.
You said you have 82 big‐box.
‐82 stores, right?
‐Just ‐‐
We're talking
about last year.
Yeah, and in November ‐‐
Sorry, Craig, did you say
that last year you sold
the incredible amount of ‐‐
how much?
$29,000 in sales...
Say it again.
... with just
a few stores.
We've focused on
making the economics
on a per‐store basis
profitable.
Mm‐hmm.
And then we launched
to 82 stores,
and only two months later,
we've been asked to launch
to 600 stores.
But what were your sales after
the balance of the stores?
This year, we're on track with
the expansion to hit $650,000.
So, you go to a store and you
say, "Put this in for free,"
or do they pay you?
Oh, you don't pay
unless it works.
They'll charge the customer
$69 for a...
‐You sell it to them?
‐$69 is expensive.
How much does it cost
to make one?
So, in the beginning,
at low production rates,
it was over $8,000 to make one
of these machines.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐$8,000?
Now it's ‐‐ Now it's less
than $3,000.
What do you charge them
for the rent on that box?
So, on average, it works out
to about $80 rent a month.
Wait. So, $80 rent per month
you're charging them?
And then on top of that,
we get a rev share ‐‐
a percentage
of the revenue...
What's ‐‐ What's
the percentage?
On average,
it's about 60%.
So, in order to do all this,
you had to have raised
a bunch of capital.
We've raised $2.2 million
so far.
‐Wow.
‐That's the key.
And what was the value
of the company post‐money?
It had a valuation cap
of $4.8 million.
So, why is your valuation
so high?
This is about getting
to $800 per month per store.
That's $6 million in revenue
and $3.5 million in profit.
But you're not
doing that today.
No, but if you
discount that back
from when
we will be doing it,
that's still
far above $10 million.
And what do you place
as a value on that risk
in case you don't execute?
Greiner:
You know, honestly, like,
I see you totally
as an online business.
We ‐‐ We ‐‐
You said you have three days,
right,
in which
it can still survive?
We have an online market,
but we haven't
been able to afford
national marketing
for the online.
I don't understand why you think
you want to go retail.
I don't see the big market.
I'm out.
Thank you.
You came in asking
for a $10 million valuation,
and I don't know how you're
gonna make that back that fast.
And so, unfortunately,
for that reason, I'm out.
I think technology
is your enemy.
I was reading something
the other day
that the new Apple phone is
almost totally water‐resistant.
So, I think that
technology improvements
can put you out of business
by the time
you figure out your model.
I wouldn't put my money there.
I'm out.
Guys, look,
I like the idea.
I like the concept.
But you're gonna have
to keep on raising capital.
And unless I gave you
that capital,
I'm gonna keep on
getting diluted.
The problem is,
how do I get my money back?
You know, one of the reasons
I think we're gonna succeed
is not just because
we may have a good plan.
It's because we have
an awesome team.
Have you ever heard
anybody start a company,
hire their people, and say,
"We have a horrible team"?
That's not enough.
I'm out.
Herjavec:
Okay, everybody's out.
Mr. Wonderful's left.
I like the story.
I understand the model.
I‐I don't want to argue about
your valuation.
I think it's too high.
I'm gonna loan you
the 500K at 13%,
but I'm taking the 5%
as an equity warrant.
That's the value I bring
as a Shark to this.
So, I want it paid back
in 36 months.
What do you think
of this offer?
Would you be willing to go
more than $500,000?
Right now,
you asked for $500,000.
That's the deal I would do.
And I'm the only Shark
here today
willing to give you
an offer.
So, what do you want to do?
♪♪
All right.
Thank you, Mr. Wonderful.
We'll take that deal.
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations, guys.
‐Thank you so much.
‐That's terrific.
Thank you very much.
Kevin, let's see how
your new investment works.
‐No, don't try it.
‐Do it, Mark.
Oh, God.
All right, guys.
Thanks.
Let's see ‐‐ [ Laughs ]
Don't even think about it.
Do it!
You got to have confidence.
Kevin, if you believe in them
and the product...
Congratulations.
Good idea.
... why not put it
in the water?
I'm not doing that.
Cookson: We're not worried
about this debt.
Mr. Wonderful,
we're gonna pay you back
and then some.
Actually,
I shouldn't say that.
[ Both laugh ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is an innovation
for running enthusiasts.
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
We are
Renata and Doug Storer,
married runners
from Orlando, Florida,
who accidentally stumbled
onto a bright idea.
We are here seeking $250,000
for a 10% stake in our company.
And the reality is,
I was the one who stumbled.
I was training
for my fifth marathon
on a dark, early‐morning
training run
when I hit a pothole
that I couldn't see,
and took a dive.
I was injured.
I hobbled home,
I came through the door,
and I said, "Honey, I need
headlights for my sneakers!"
He actually did say that,
and he does have
a brilliant idea
every once in a while.
[ Chuckles ]
The result was
Night Runner 270 shoe lights.
They provide 270 degrees
of visibility around you...
Wow.
... 150 lumens out in front...
Oh, wow.
... with a 30‐foot
beam distance
to identify any trip hazards
that might be in your path.
Night Runners
are weather‐resistant...
so they will weather
the pouring rain
and uneven terrain.
Night Runner lets active people
do what they love to do
and stay safe
and injury‐free.
Now, we know Sharks
love to feed in the night,
so who's hungry
for a bright idea?
[ Light laughter ]
Now, we have Night Runners
for each one of you.
Oh.
We also have some shoes,
if we have any volunteers that
would like to try them out.
Sure.
You got a size 12?
I do.
I'll pass Lori hers, too.
It would ruin my outfit.
I'm staying right here.
‐Here you go, Kevin.
‐Thank you.
Here you go.
So, with the shoes untied,
you slip them on
to the top row.
So, it slips ‐‐
it goes under here like this?
Close the doors!
Cuban: It's nice.
Actually, you don't notice
that they're there.
‐They look great, Mark.
‐It's very cool.
You can't tell you're
wearing them, can you?
No, no.
They feel very secure.
So, what do these lights
sell for?
These lights sell
for $59.95.
We ‐‐ We wholesale them
for $30.
What do they cost you
to make?
We get them shipped and landed
for $15.50.
We've sold 6,000 of them.
What are your sales?
Dollars to date
are $260,000.
We've only been in operation
for eight months.
Wow.
What do you think you're gonna
sell this year and next year,
and how much money
are you gonna make?
So, this year, with investment,
would be a $760,000 year,
and that's 20,000 units.
What do you mean,
"with investment"?
So, we have
enough inventory on hand
to do an organic year
of about $300,000.
You mean you don't have
enough money
to buy enough inventory
to sell more?
Right.
So, how much
do you guys have left?
We have about $15,000.
Okay. So your back's
up against the wall.
Corcoran: When I go out biking
in the morning,
I can hardly find a spot
on the road in Central Park.
That's how many bikers
are out there.
Right.
I rarely see
someone running at night,
and that's a city
of eight million people.
I mistrust the quantity of
people who want to run at night,
so I'm out,
just based on that.
Well, I‐I appreciate that,
but I would like to also mention
the Night Shift basically ‐‐
Oh, there's more?
‐There is more.
‐Oh.
It's called
the Night Shift.
It's for
the occupational‐safety market.
It is for people
who work at night.
It is for construction workers,
D. O. T. road workers.
Ohh, you're going
way out there now.
No, that's not bad.
That's smart.
No, this is a way ‐‐
Anybody who works in the dark
that has shoelaces.
Greiner: It's important,
because they get hit by cars.
They do.
That's a little more
interesting,
because I could see
broader investment applications.
Yeah, you put this
on a work boot.
I mean, part of the problem
is you named it Night Runner,
and there's your work boots
right there.
Well, that's why
the ‐‐ the new model
will be ‐‐ be called
Night Shift.
This is
the real game changer.
We know we can get our feet wet
with the athletic market,
but the occupational‐safety
market,
we feel,
can be much bigger.
Herjavec: But, like,
why can't you do that right now?
Why can't the existing product
do that?
Just ‐‐ Just resources.
If you got to work
an entire shift,
you need it to last
8 to 10 hours.
Oh, it's the battery life
that's the problem.
‐Did we...
‐It's ‐‐ Yeah.
These are meant
for over four hours.
I think you guys
have done a great job.
I think we can really help you
with expanding the product line.
I'll give you the $250,000
for 30%.
Okay, so, I like it, too.
I was thinking
I was gonna go out,
but when you showed me
the product
for the industrial‐safety
and walking market,
that got my juices flowing.
That makes a lot more sense
to me.
If it becomes
a standard safety item,
the mining industry's
gonna be huge with this,
the security market
at night.
That really appeals to me.
I would do this ‐‐
$250,000 for 15%.
You've got to grab that
right away.
Yes?
Greiner:
I got a question for you.
Okay.
You could take
Kevin's offer,
or you could take
Robert's offer.
Or you could take
what's behind door number two.
Wouldn't you be
door number three by now?
I don't have to be number three.
It's door number two.
So, you want to ask yourself,
"Do I feel lucky?"
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Renata and Doug
have two offers on the table
for their shoe light,
Night Runner 270.
But Lori also seems interested.
Do you have an offer,
Lori?
$300,000 for 20%.
So, I'm gonna give you
a little bit more money,
asking a little more equity.
I'm not a runner.
I'm a walker.
But I love it
because it's just smart product.
Right.
And that's why I want
to be involved with it ‐‐
'cause product's what I do.
Wow.
Well, thank you very much.
I tell you, preparing
for this opportunity...
‐Hmm.
... we said, "Gosh,
every single one of you
offers something..."
What a schmoozer.
"...that we need."
So, we are ‐‐ Our sales
are increasing in
the Southern hemisphere.
Remember, you have three offers
on the table.
Why are you keeping everybody
waiting as you're selling?
Out of respect,
just out of respect.
Stop selling.
Focus on the offers.
Okay.
So, you have three offers ‐‐
Robert's $250,000 for 30%...
Right.
... Lori's $300,000 for 20%,
and I'm $250,000 for 15%.
Mm‐hmm.
You've got to kind of
make a decision.
Hey, Doug, so, listen ‐‐
I'm gonna change my offer.
I'll give you $200,000
for 15%,
because I think that's
the cash to buy inventory,
get the product out.
On top of that, I'll give you
$150,000 as a pure loan.
Okay.
So, my total offer is $350,000,
in effect, for 15%.
But $150,000 of it is debt.
Is a loan.
I'll throw in an offer
just to tell you where I'm at.
It's gonna take
a lot of work.
So, what I'll do is I'll
offer you the 250K for 30%,
but I'll offer you unlimited
purchase‐order financing.
Mark's going the other way.
He's back up to the 30%.
Could we have a minute
to talk about this?
‐Absolutely.
‐Thank you.
We're not gonna go far.
[ Sighs ]
So, what do you think?
These are all
good offers.
Robert obviously is the most
in tune with ‐‐ with running.
It's a lot of work.
I'm not saying
the other ones aren't.
I don't like it
for the running market.
I like it
for everything else.
But Kevin believes in
the occupational‐safety market.
Right.
That's the highest valuation.
What about going in all together
for the 30%?
Count me out.
I don't even get this product.
If we're gonna do that,
why don't we go up
to 35% or something?
‐Yeah, why don't you?
‐Why don't we?
They're
at their last $15,000.
Guys, before ‐‐ before
you start,
while you were away,
we also talked amongst
ourselves, okay?
One of the risks
of leaving the room.
And that's always a risk
in "Shark Tank."
Sometimes it's good.
Sometimes it's bad.
Let me explain.
You've now got two offers
across four Sharks,
broken up this way ‐‐
Mark's offer is ‐‐
he's the lone wolf now.
He's gonna make you
that offer ‐‐
$250,000 for 30%.
And the financing.
The other three Sharks
really like that offer a lot.
We're gonna make the same.
You're gonna get three Sharks
for the same amount.
We'll give you the $250,000
for 30%, three Sharks,
with all the benefits
they have.
They decided to copy me
for obvious reasons.
But, you know,
competition happens.
We all like the deal, so ‐‐
Herjavec: Well, we ‐‐ we ‐‐
I think we thought
you were willing
to give up more equity.
I'll be honest
with you.
We came in here looking at 20%
being a ‐‐ being a ceiling.
Is there ‐‐
Is there any offers
that would cap the equity
at 20%?
‐Not mine.
‐Okay.
Not ours.
You just got
a lot of work to do.
If you really want the benefit
of multiple Sharks,
you got to leave them a little
bit of meat on the bone.
Greiner:
Well, you came back in
saying you wanted to do it
for 20%.
Right?
‐Yes.
And I had offered you $300,000
for 20%.
So, I would do the $250,000
Oh, you're leaving
the team now.
[ Chuckles ]
‐Interesting.
‐Well...
That's a Sharky move.
There's no unity on the team
anymore.
Obviously, these alignments
can fall out of favor
very quickly.
But I'm a Shark.
So...
O'Leary:
But I would do the ‐‐
You got to kind of take that
right now.
I'll go back to mine.
I'll do the $250,000 for 15%.
And, Doug, you know what?
I'll go back to my ‐‐
‐Wow.
‐That's amazing!
I will go back
to my original offer.
I'll give you
my original offer ‐‐
$300,000 for 20%.
I'll do $350,000 for 15%.
I don't believe this.
It's nuts.
‐Oh, my God.
Would you like a notepad?
[ Chuckling ] Yes.
Robert is $200,000 for 15%,
plus $150,000 of debt
for your inventory,
Lori is $300,000 for 20%,
and I am $250,000 for 15%,
and Mark is $250,000 for 30%.
For 30% still.
With unlimited financing.
Okay.
All right,
what do you guys want to do?
Okay.
[ Indistinct whispering ]
‐Okay.
‐Let's do it.
All right, first of all,
thank you so much
for all of the offers.
I‐I want to ask Kevin ‐‐
Yeah?
Do you have the same passion
for the other markets
that you do the
occupational‐safety market?
I have a passion
to make money.
You show me the direction
you want to put your focus on,
I'll support you.
Doug, you need somebody that
knows this market with you...
I know this market.
... that ‐‐ that actually
uses a product.
Why did you ask me
that question?
I'll do the $250,000
for 15%
and the $100,000
of it as a loan.
It doesn't matter.
You're getting $350,000 in cash.
Don't make an investment
with somebody
who doesn't actually understand
or use the product.
I mean, that's just ‐‐
That's ridiculous.
That's a really
ridiculous statement.
The only time Kevin runs
is to lunch.
I'm a fine‐tuned athlete.
I could kick his ass in squash
every day.
Robert,
let me ask you this ‐‐
Herjavec: Yes, sir?
Would you go in with Lori
at 20% for two Sharks?
I'm in.
Lori?
‐No. I'm sorry.
‐Okay.
I think, if it were
the two of us together,
like we were doing before,
then you have to be at the 30%.
Okay.
So, then, Robert, I accept
your offer of $250,000 at 15%.
Wow.
‐Interesting outcome.
‐And that's Robert.
I'm going with Lori.
I'm going with Kevin.
‐Oh, thank you.
‐Thank you, guys.
Thank you so much.
Cuban: Congratulations, guys.
Congrats.
‐Appreciate it.
‐That was great.
‐Thanks for the shoes.
‐You're welcome.
Thank you!
Wow.
Doug: I think we walked
out of the Tank
looking at each other and
saying, "What just happened?"
And we're still trying
to figure that out.
But we know that
with Robert on board,
we've got a bright future.
Herjavec:
A lot of stuff happened.
We got together.
The Sharks hate each other.
Lori turned on me.
[ Greiner laughs ]
They played their hand
really well.
They were very calm.
All they did was let the Sharks
go at each other.
I know.
And she was freaking out
the entire time...
But they didn't
move on it.
...'cause they knew
they had no cash.
15 grand in the bank ‐‐
that's scary.
They were smart.
Good luck, Robert.
♪♪